La parte de vidrio de una ventana tiene una proporción de 3 a 2 entre su largo y su ancho,
entonces lo alto del vidrio, vamos a subrayar esto, lo alto del vidrio se puede representar como
3x y el ancho del vidrio se puede representar como 2x,
¿Ok? El ancho del vidrio se puede representar como 2x. Ahora la orilla de
madera añade 7 centímetros en total al ancho.
El ancho, lo estábamos dibujando con naranja entonces esto va con
naranja, al ancho de la ventana y 8 centímetros al largo de la ventana.
Entonces le agrega 8 centímetros al largo ¿Ok? Entonces
tenemos aquí nuestra ventana, que tiene proporciones 3 a 2
entre su largo y su ancho y nos dicen que la parte de vidrio de la ventana,
esta es la parte de vidrio de la ventana,
todo este pedazo, que me está quedando un poco chueco pero, ya ni modo.
Todo este pedazo es la parte de vidrio de la ventana,
aquí tiene un poco de madera pero pues no nos están diciendo sus medidas entonces vamos a pensar que es parte del vidrio, y lo
que nos están diciendo es que lo alto del vidrio se puede representar como 3x ¿ok? Entonces
esta medida de aquí se puede representar como
3x y por otro lado tenemos que la orilla de madera
añade unos 8 centímetros al largo ¿Ok? Entonces este pedazo más este pedazo de aquí,
añaden 8 centímetros al largo. Entonces el largo total,
toda esta longitud,
mide 3x del largo de la parte de vidrio de la ventana más,
8 de la parte de madera de la ventana.
¿Ok? Esto es el largo. Ahora vamos a medir el ancho.
Nosotros sabemos que este pedazo se puede representar como 2x aunque todo esto de aquí
mide 2x pero, la orilla de madera añade unos 7 centímetros.
Este pedazo más este otro pedazo le está agregando unos siete centímetros.
Entonces el total del ancho de la ventana, lo vamos a escribir por acá,
mide 2x, este 2x más los 7centímetros que añade la madera más
7 ¿Ok? Y nos están pidiendo que encontremos un polinomio en términos de x que represente el
área total de la ventana,
incluyendo la parte de vidrio y la parte de madera ¿Ok? Entonces el área total de todo esto tiene que ser base,
esta base por altura que es todo esto. Entonces él área
es igual a nuestra base que es
2x más 7 por la altura que es 3x más 8 por 3x
más 8 y listo ya tenemos el área de la ventana.
Pero esto es una multiplicación de dos binomios no es precisamente un polinomio.
¿Ok? Entonces tenemos que desarrollar esta multiplicación
para llegar al polinomio. Así es que esto es igual a, tenemos que multiplicar
2x por 3x y después 2x por 8 y una vez que terminemos con eso vamos a sumarle
7 por 3x más 7 por 8
¿Ok? Pero empezamos
2x por 3x, 2x por 3x más
2x por 8, 2x por 8.
Recuerda que tenemos que multiplicar cada uno de los elementos de este paréntesis por cada uno de los elementos de este paréntesis.
Ya terminamos con 2x por que ya los tenemos con 3x y con 8, entonces vamos a pasar con 7.
Tenemos aquí más 7 por 3x
7 por 3x más 7 por 8, 7 por 8
y todo esto es igual a
pues 2 por 3 es un 6 y "x" por "x" es "x" cuadrada más 2 por 8
16x , "x"  más 7 por 3, 21x
más finalmente 7 por 8 56
Ahora uno puede pensar que ya terminamos por que esto ya es un polinomio
pero, siempre que se pueda simplificar hay que hacerlo y estos dos
términos se pueden sumar y formar un solo término ¿Ok? Por que tenemos una sola "x"
entonces tenemos 16x más 21x eso es
37x y ya nada más tenemos que bajar este por acá y nos queda
6x cuadrada más
56 y listo esta es el área de nuestra ventana en forma de un polinomio en términos de "x".